[Music]
iconic she's an artist she is the
history of fashion like no other
designer she's a legend modern graphic
and power ridiculous she's a visionary
I'm talking about obviously I first
encountered Edna's work I remember
sitting in Paris it was Paris Couture
Marseillaise excited I wanna show the
Chanel do maybe I'll see you in a mood
to talk and here comes Edna explosive
jumpsuit Edna Moyes collection was such
a feast for the eyes it's like no one
else unlike anything I had ever seen
when she designed a dress for me for the
Emmys and I knew that I've made it as a
model so - some show and pray and Mila
that cycle in siog Louis Vuitton Edna
she's a visionary a giant I mean well
not literally she comes up to my knees
hmm my favorite add new piece the
nuclear onesie the bulletproof romper
the Rockettes stilettos he's done Regis
everyone has their the Beast and they
can all pull it off simple and get it oh
she's very intimidating no Kate no cape
no kiss no comment Edna hates capes
so we all hate capes have you ever heard
anything so ludicrous Edna's a divisive
figure but at the end of the day she's a
visionary I would say Edna mode is like
the modern-day Andy Warhol but I think
Andy Warhol looked up to her
bravo Bravo darling Thank You Edna
you're the best of the best
I know
[Music]
um they said I was gonna get an Edna
piece because I did the interview
[Music]